Christie's an Alabama hi Christie your
question for Chris it's actually a
question for both of you I need I need
advice I'm not going a lot my husband
and I are in a call it a financial well
my income went from in 2018 it was
roughly around a hundred thousand due to
medical issues and things this year
we're going to be around 40,000 we were
already behind before the medical things
hit and now we're just even more behind
and I recently got diagnosed with
congestive heart failure so we're
looking to even more medical debt and
everything associated with that as we
were trying to climb out of this hole
and we just really don't even know where
to go next
how much debt have you got it's right at
one hundred and fifty thousand student
loans some credit cards a car most it's
mostly the student loans how much your
student I wandered around 65,000 okay
and what is the other 85,000 how much a
card that it's five thousand huh credit
you got a bunch of credit card debt down
yeah I had some really really stupid
moments in college and my early 20s and
I'm paying for it
Erol you got like eighty thousand
dollars in credit cards um somewhere
around in there yes sir goodness
gracious Gail have you cut them up yes
they've been cut up for right at a year
all right that's a good plan alright and
so you've had medical problems as your
husband as well no he he's a general
manager at a car wash so he doesn't I
was about 75% of our income my income
got cut about 50% along day two hours
and then I was out for about six months
I'm sorry it's a congestive heart
failure have you got that under control
to where you're able to work again I am
my main job I haven't been getting many
hours so I've actually put in
applications to find another one and
been doing food delivery anywhere from
10 to 12 hours a day just you bring your
money I work for a medical records
company I'm an audit specialist okay and
you used to make at the high point how
much 2018 2017 2018 I made right at 85
to 90 thousand okay so that's where
we're headed back to cuz that solves the
problem it really does it really does
Christie and and right now what your
feeling is is you've had Murphy visit
you you've heard Dave talk about that
that's where the stuff that can go wrong
it does and right now you and your
husband need to take a deep breath and
get on the same page that you can't
borrow your way out of this okay there's
not a magic button you're gonna hit
that's gonna fix it there do they talk
about the easy button on TV that is just
for commercials this is gonna require
you all really buckling down being
intentional and really having a clear
plan of walking through the principles
we teach at Financial Peace University
the debt snowball you can do this but
you're going to have to stay extremely
intentional so he's a manager at a car
wash right yes sir in the big issue were
having right now is when I was out of
work for six months due to injury my
short-term disability was maybe a
quarter and mine come so we're so far
behind in a lot of our bills that we're
scraping by to get our house payment and
keep the lights on a lot of money so
it's trying to figure out how to get
caught up with those so that we can
start the baby steps
yeah you don't you only be worried about
baby steps gonna be worried about what
we call the four walls so the first
thing you do you write out your budget
in detail and the two of you look at it
we do anything we can do to create
income within your health parameters
that you've got he's working extra
you're changing jobs we're moving in the
right direction your first things food
then you pay your lights and water are
you current on those yes we are then you
pay your house payment are you current
on it yes sir
good okay are you crying on the car
payment I'm one behind on it but I think
I should we had that cutter buddy
our middle of next week when you write
out your budget breathe this with me
when you know you can eat keep the
lights on and have a place to stay in
something to drive you can breathe the
rest of this is a Monopoly game but
those are life if you so breathe peace
in knowing that the four walls of your
home are protected food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities you got
that and the rest of this is a game and
you're going into the second half of the
football game and you're behind right
now you'll get caught up and work
through we'll help you we're gonna put
you through Financial Peace University
as our guest okay so you hold on
we'll have Kelly pick up and we'll get
you in the class and have some folks to
walk with you but you take care of the
necessities first and then rest in the
peace of that you know and then fight
from there that's exactly right and you
contact those other creditors and you
let them know you're gonna pay them when
you can you're taking care of those four
walls first